[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dan
lebotard the artist formerly known as
dan
levitar how do i introduce you dan uh
well not formerly what is this you go to
you go to espn you leave espn and you
immediately become
formerly no no i don't want to become
formerly anything you can introduce me
by my name as your friend
dan levitar following in your footsteps
trying to do the pioneering thing of
breaking
free from the mothership
uh any uh trepidation when you decided
to leave or now that you left
i i bring this up that i came home made
the right move and then six weeks later
i'm at home by myself with
the family dog and i went ah i think i
just made a
terrible mistake any of those feelings
um
satur every day and saturdays are pretty
cool right up until
every day is saturday and then you're
like wait a minute i've lost a sense of
time uh
there's always going to be doubt and
fear and pain
when you leave something comfortable i
have learned later in life it took me a
long time to learn it
that you should generally lean into the
fear and the doubt and the pain it's
where you need to be going to
get to growth so it took me a long time
to learn that but it is something to
lean into so of course
i'm also responsible you know this dan
you and i have talked about this
i'm i'm responsible for a lot of people
i'm responsible for a lot of people i
care about and so it's more of the
pressure of that
if if not for the pressure that i might
already be on a boat somewhere
far away from you know debating whether
or not chris paul
fits in oklahoma city what exactly are
you doing
and what are the plans for the future
it's a very broad question what i would
say is
i am vigorously enjoying
and taking advantage of the freedom
that i did not realize had a great deal
of power to it when you are
us our businesses have been run by
middlemen and
agents and agencies for a long time and
it's been a bit
startling to see once you get outside of
the corporate machine
oh my god there's a whole playground
here of people who want to work with you
creatives who want to do stuff with you
who are starved
for similar freedom so i i've just seen
a lot of instances already where
i've been moved right as the son of
cuban exiles i've been moved by
freedom being even bigger than i
imagined and freedom has always been the
thing i've negotiated freedom has always
been front of mind it's always been
priority but to see
maximum freedom you can work with
anybody you can choose
anything you want i don't know that i
deserve
what it is that that is because it fills
me with a great deal of gratitude
uh to be free of all shackles
to be able to speak my mind without any
encumbering whatsoever
and to work only the rest of the way dan
only
with people i like i don't have to do it
anymore i do not have to work
with anybody i don't like the rest of my
life that's not going to happen
let's name some names here do you want
to you want to get that out there too
people people i don't like yes people i
don't like
um i what is it you go first
given what what's the disparagement
language in your contract
what are the confidential confidential
you know i left with all my stuff
you know i got out of espn and i took i
was able to leave with all my stuff
right so i i am not allowed to say bad
things about certain people that was the
trade
you know what i took i got my ties all
my
ties that i wore on the air that was it
and you have a lot of them though yes i
i don't know if these
it can be non-fungible tokens now in the
new commerce economy that i don't
understand
but maybe these ties are worth something
or videos of these ties or worth
something
yeah but also that you know the media
landscape is
changing i don't know if it's ever
changed
this fast right i mean i mean it's
unbelievable how fast it's changed i've
i've been amazed by this dan like
this happened to newspapers right
newspapers were throwing yesterday's
news on your lawn and asking you to pay
for it and giving it to you more
immediately on your computer for free
and of course it kills newspapers radio
doesn't pay attention
television doesn't pay attention movies
don't pay attention and all of them get
swallowed by the same thing which is
today i get what i want
when i want it i don't i don't live by a
television schedule
i don't live by when you want to give me
television or radio
i am on demand all the time and so
uh this is a great time to be free
because this is a golden age of content
and you know one of the companies
keeping up our economy
is netflix and the others who want to
get into the game are
amazon and google and everybody else i
was actually surprised
to see football and hockey go
traditional routes or largely
traditional routes
old school television streaming rights
as opposed to
uh you know choosing some of these new
models because this game is going to be
totally different
in five years dan because here comes the
gambling money too like
it's like in five years all of this is
going to be hugely different than it is
right now
what is the big topic that you guys have
been dealing with with your podcast
is there a sports topic that uh has been
front and center
our specialty and no one else can have
it is just narcissistic
ego soaked naval gazing that is
the number one thing that we do uh and
as it relates to sports we enjoy talking
about the miami heat a lot because we've
uh over the last 10 years in miami uh
basketball it's been cool to learn a lot
about basketball just the measurements
watching i mean
how long have you been doing this dan it
is rare to be watching sports
and see whether it's the shift in
baseball or the way that the three-point
line has dominated basketball where you
see
evolutions that make you wonder hey
how good would shaq be today wait a
minute andre drummond went from
something i wanted to something i'm
not sure i want anymore because
everybody is outspread out on the
perimeter
like you never get to see real-time
evolutions in sports or
live through them like that where you
realize it not looking back on it but
watching it in real time
how's your wife doing uh she's a source
of perpetual happiness uh my muse and
the reason that i was able to summon
uh the ability to leave the safest
platform in sports to uh
to jump off a cliff because i want to
follow love and freedom
thank you for asking by the way the
audience should know
uh well i'm not going to even say this
on the air i'm not go
i was going to tell the audience that my
wife wishes you were her father but i
would never do that i don't want to say
that on the air so i'm glad we're not
talking about this publicly
and i you know i would sing that madonna
song i will be your father figure put
your tiny hand in mind and
your wife would then sing along with me
and i will be inappropriate
stop flirting with my wife stop
serenading my wife stop singing to my
wife and
make me deeply uncomfortable more
uncomfortable than i was just making
making her your father making you her
father
was there any thought of not taking
stugots when you left
uh not from my end there were many
thoughts from stu godz of just
uh because i'm william h macy and boogie
nights
in terms of my marriage where i always
end up on the parking lot in the parking
lot
and there's two gods flirting with golic
you know like
from my hand i always intended to be
with god
well you know you were at the wedding
didn't he drive you home because he was
didn't he angle for a job with you yes
he did
yes he did yes he did um hey uh happy to
glad to talk to you and uh my best
everybody there and uh hopefully we'll
cross paths here soon i love you buddy
always good
uh talking to you take care that's uh
dan levitar
he's uh host uh podcast he's doing a lot
of different things